Ngày Mi sau thóng mẹ hai thâu dự Mỹ, tổng thống Mỹ đôn nân trong trường biết đã xa lệnh phóng tỏa toàn diện và trị đầy.
Đối với các tạo trường dầu bị trinh pháp, đi vào về giờ khỏi video dưới la.
Thông báo đưa ra trong buổi cảnh Mỹ thích thủng giả tăng cây biển pháp gây sức ếp,
nhằm vào chính quyền tổng thống Nicolas Maduro.
Theo các quán chuyển thống Mỹ, Washington trở biệt, biển pháp này được thực hiện với sự hiện diện tăng cường
gục các lực lượng quân sự và thực thị pháp lột chi biển, nhằm bảo đàn về thực thị cây
tệnh trường pháp hiện hành, giải chung Mỹ nhảm mạnh, một tiêu lần nằm chẳng thông hòa động bị nghi ngờ
liên quan đêm bú lộn dồ mò và các dòng tài chính bẩn bị cho là hỗ trợ những hành vi vý pháp lột pháp
của tế.
Về phía bên dưới giờ là chỉ vụ nãy đã gửi công hàm tưởng hội đồng bá liền của phản đối việc
Mỹ thù dưới tàu và hàng hòa dồ mòa trên vụ biển của tế.
Thời ra khá sâu rằng, càng đồng này vi phạm công ước liền của vệ luật biển và sân phạm